en moscú siguen las reacciones a las
palabras del presidente joe biden que
dijo que vladimir putin no podía
permanecer en el poder en el que hermine
han calificado las palabras de biden de
alarmantes el portavoz de la presidencia
rusa dmitri peskov ha dicho que el
término va a continuar siguiendo de
manera muy atenta todas las
declaraciones que se hacen al respecto
desde eeuu altos cargos de eeuu allá
matizaron que byd en no se refería a que
washington buscase un cambio en el poder
en rusia pero para entonces las
declaraciones del presidente
norteamericano ya habían tenido
respuesta desde moscú que considera que
estas palabras reducen las posibilidades
de mejorar las relaciones entre ambos
países también ha recordado el portavoz
ruso a la casa blanca que no corresponde
a eeuu decidir quién está en el poder en
rusia pero más duro todavía ha sido el
presidente del parlamento ruso de la
cámara baja- beach island volodin ha
dicho que sólo corresponde a los
psiquiatras juzgar las declaraciones de
biden al cual ha definido como una
persona débil y enferma